good
ladies and gentlemen welcome to episode
you
hey youtubers its charlie huge news
first teaser for Star Wars Episode 8
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the force awakens because this is a
scene directly from the force awakens
what's going on here there reshooting
the scene from the end of the force
awakens JJ Abrams crew shot this for
episode 7 on Selig Michael I've already
done a video about that Island because
there's a lot of real-world cultural
significance that feeds into what Luke
Skywalker is doing in the new movie
searching for the origins of the Jedi
the first Jedi Temple so it's a very
special Island in the movies it's a very
special Island in real life so they're
probably going to be spending some time
there in episode 8 maybe the beginning
it seems like Luke Skywalker is going to
take on an obi-wan
type role but if you felt like episode 7
was a carbon copy of episodes 4 and 5
think of episode 8 is going a little
off-book I think with episode 7 they
just wanted to show fans
hey we're honoring the original stuff
we're not throwing everything out so I
think they're giving ryan johnson who
wrote episodes 8 & 9 like he wrote the
rest of the trilogy
he's only directing episode 8 someone
else is directing episode 9 i think when
he sat down to write those next two
movies they gave him a little more
creative license to go in different
directions like be as creative as you
want with the characters but obviously
it's still gonna be Star Wars it's still
gonna look and feel like star wars it
just won't be a carbon copy of a
previous Star Wars movie in the way star
wars the force awakens was the really
big question I know everyone's asking is
is why do they need to reshoot that last
scene from the force awakens again there
are two big reasons I could think of
right off the bat one they want episode
8 to pick up immediately after episode 7
as if you were to like stack them both
end and it would feel like a four hour
movie or a five hour movie depending on
how long both of them are or two there's
just gonna be an expanded version of
that scene with Luke Skywalker dialogue
like he'll actually speak somewhere in
Episode eight
but if Luke Skywalker spent all that
time trying to find that original temple
there's no way they're not going to
spend at least a little bit of time
there explaining what's so important
about it next really awesome thing he'll
probably spend some time training Rey
after they get past that initial WTF
look like oh my god you have my father's
lightsaber is going down it's only
going to get worse from here remember
Snoke told kylo Ren it's time to
complete your training same things gonna
be happening with Rey I think we'll
learn more about how Rey got stranded on
jakku we might even learn
who her parents are I don't know if
they're ready to reveal that completely
but they just cast Laura Dern for an
unspecified role so she could be like
the forged ghost of Rey's mother and if
a really is Luke Skywalker's daughter as
most people believe that's the most
widely held belief right now Luke
Skywalker's dead wife if you have no
idea who Laura Dern is just re-watched
the first Jurassic Park movie she's a
complete badass she's a great actress so
I'm really excited of all the Star Wars
films to go off book like when we got
the prequels and it Ryan with the
original trilogy but it looked very
different and George Lucas did work very
hard to make them look different even if
thematically they were very similar
episode 8 is probably gonna be the most
different Star Wars film that you've
seen so far but he's a great director
he's a great writer I'm really excited
to see where he takes the Star Wars
universe if you were one of those people
that had complaints about stuff that JJ
Abrams did with the first movie I feel
like Rian Johnson is your answer to that
so if you want a really awesome Rian
Johnson movie you can watch brick you
can watch looper that's a good example
of like a big Hollywood movie brick is a
smaller indie movie that would be
awesome by itself break only done in the
Star Wars universe so now that we've
started episode 8 I'm probably gonna
start working on Episode 8 videos if you
have any special bonus video requests
just let me know in the comments if you
guys haven't seen it I've already done a
big Easter Egg video for episode 7 you
can click here for that and you can
click here to learn all about why that
island that they're add is so special
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys
tonight
you